un chiffre maintenant 122
1484 c'est le nombre de signatures de la
pétition anti chasse déposé en septembre
dernier sur la plateforme du sénat
l'avait été lancé vous vous en souvenez
évidemment après la mort d'un jeune
homme tué par un chasseur alors qu'il
coupait du bois dans son jardin six mois
plus tard c'est une randonneuse qui
vient de mourir lors d'une battue au
sanglier c'est dans le cantal pour la
mission d'information sur la
sécurisation de la chasse la pression
est forte norbert evangelista a suivi
des sénateurs il était à marly-le-roi on
est dans les yvelines et il venait
assister aux épreuves du permis de
chasse justement regarder
ceci est un exercice qui simule une
battue une pratique courante à la chasse
mais qui obéit à des règles strictes en
particulier celle de délimiter un angle
de tir au delà duquel le chasseur n'a
plus le droit de tirer c'est une des
épreuves à laquelle est soumis le
candidat au permis de chasser une autre
épreuve est éliminatoire si le candidat
ne s'est distingué une proie d'une
silhouette humaine avec une arme à la
main ce qu'on va attendre le jour de
l'examen c'est que le candidat prennent
un temps de réflexion avant d'effectuer
les bons gestes ce semblant d'examen est
suivi de près par des sénateurs de la
mission chargée d'étudier les questions
relatives à la sécurité à la chasse elle
intervient quelques jours à peine après
la mort d'une randonneuse tué par une
jeune femme de 17 ans détentrice d'un
permis qu'on peut obtenir en france dès
l'âge de 16 ans je ne peux pas vous
répondre sur un nuage en tant que tel ce
que je vais vous dire c'est que il y à
une réflexion à avoir faire en sorte à
mon sens qu'une forme de gradation dans
l'acquisition
d'une armée dont le manipulation de la
main une gradation qui pourrait passer
par la délivrance d'un permis calqué sur
l'obtention du permis de conduire un
examen qui se déroule sur deux ou trois
dimanche accompagné avec des maîtres de
deux stages et dire c'est possible ou
c'est pas possible il n'a pas encore
acquis la maturité au long faut
réfléchir à peut-être un permis
probatoire parmi les sénateurs sophie
primas chasseuse elle-même fort mise sur
ce site d'une des 13 fédérations de
france l'une des seules à prendre en
charge les personnes qui encadrent la
chasse je pense en particulier dans
cette fédération d'ile-de-france à la
formation des responsables de chasse des
responsables de monde de tir les
chasseurs quant à eux prêts à toute
réforme du permis pour réduire encore
les accidents tiennent à quelques mises
au point il ya beaucoup plus d'accidents
soit d'auto accident soit d'accident
n'était des tiers qui sont causés par
des chasseurs plus âgé que par les
jeunes il rappelle aussi que grâce à la
formation en vingt ans les accidents de
chasse ont diminué de plus d'un tiers
aux france
cette question de la formation du permis
de chasser aussi la question de jours
sans chasse
voilà les thématiques dont on va parler
tout de suite dans ce débat et
j'accueille françois patriat bonsoir
vous en soi sénateurs l om de la
côte-d'or président du groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant ici au
sénat guillaume montaron soir sénateur
europe ecologie les verts de l'isère et
président du groupe écologie solidarité
et territoires au sénat andrée corvol
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes directrice
de recherche au cnrs spécialiste de la
chasse et auteur d'une histoire de la
chasse l'homme et la bête c'est aux
éditions perrin matthieu croissandeau
toujours à mes côtés évidemment françois
patriat peut-être une question un peu
général pour démarrer sur cette pétition
on vient de voir les sénateurs sur le
terrain dans les yvelines comment
répondre à la demande qui était quand
même forte de des plus de 122 mille
personnes qui ont signé cette pétition
il faut il faut y répondre
redonnant à la chasse le sens qu'ils
doivent aujourd'hui on retrouve en un
peu de recul par rapport à celle d'hier
à l'agitation quotidienne faire
comprendre que la chasse
un territoire rural fait partie de la
vie qu'elle n'est pas un danger
permanent qu'elle n'est pas rejeter que
dans le milieu urbain je peux comprendre
aujourd'hui qu'on ne comprenne pas la
chasse comprend pas l'achat il ya cette
aspiration aujourd'hui vous savez au
bien être animal à la douleur qui fait
partie maintenant d'autres sites etc et
différentes descentes et se rappeler
malgré tout que la principale
revendication de la révolution française
était la chasse à l'époque c'était parce
qu'on a parce qu'il y avait des famines
et madame vraiment de me dira bien bien
mieux que moi mais
moi qui suis chasseur je comprends bien
la difficulté qu'il y a aujourd'hui a
expliqué la chasse à des gens qui vivent
en ville tous les jours dans ma nature
je le comprends mais je vous rappeler de
vous redire et tout à l'heure comment
j'avais mené il ya 20 ans j'étais
monsieur sache pour le gouvernement
lionel jospin j'ai fait un rapport de
110 propositions qui aboutit une loi qui
a fait progresser les choses en
l'occurrence progresser et qu'à l'époque
j'avais proposé dans la loi
l'établissement d'un jour de non chasse
le choc qui avait été voté au sénat et
cliente qui avait été voté à l'assemblée
qui a été voté au sénat et qui après le
renversement du gouvernement a été
supprimée par le sénat en bas ça sera
lundi mounir on y reviendra évidemment
guillaume gontard plus de 122 mille
signataires de cette pétition était
intitulé more violences et abus liés à
la chasse était uniquement des urbains
un peu déconné de du monde rural je
pense pas moi je suis je suis allée
maire d'une commune de moins de 100
habitants j'y vis depuis depuis 50 ans
donc je pense que non c'est une
problématique générale et je pense qu'il
faut peut-être justement déconnecté de
la question pour ou contre la chasse qui
est un débat qui voit là tu peux être
intéressant mais là il ya de vraies
questions de sécurité et cette pétition
elle a été proposée en fait suite au
décès de morgan keenan tuées dans dans
son jardin 25 ans
mélody qu'aux faits qui a été tuée la
semaine le week-end dernier et on voit
qu'on a des drames particulier en plus
qui touche qui touchent des jeunes est
tout simplement qui est un vrai problème
de sécurité qu'on ne peut pas en rester
là et qu'on ne peut pas voilà chaque
fois dire bon bah oui c'est un drame
mais ça fait partie de la chasse non je
pense qu'on doit arriver sur un risque
zéro il n'est pas acceptable qu'on
puisse prendre un risque en allant se
promener en randonnant faisant du vtt
mois en 2015 sur le département de
l'isère c'est une personne sur un chemin
de randonnée qui est décédé pareil 20
ans et donc je pense qu'on peut pas se
satisfaire cette situation et donc il
faut prendre les choses de manière très
pragmatique c'est un peu ce qui a été
dit c'est comment on peut mieux encadrer
et qu'on voit qu'on a beaucoup de choses
à faire on en reparlera bonnette
propositions à faire et notamment sur
des journées des temps sans chasse ça
c'est évident un chiffre qui concerne la
saison de chasse 2020 2021 sur le nombre
d'accidents 80 dont 7 mortels sont des
chiffres donnés par la fédération
nationale des chasseurs andrée corvol
est-ce que la chasse est plus ou moins
sûr enfin je vous posais la question de
façon différente est-ce que il ya moins
d'accidents et est ce que l'opinion a
évolué et qu'on les accepte moins voyez
ce que je veux dire et les des
phénomènes d'une part y est
effectivement moins d'accidents en
raison des progrès qui ont été apportées
dans le permis de chasse qui est devenu
le permis de chasser de ce point de vue
là il ya eu de nets progrès du point de
vue de la sécurité et le chiffre des
accidents de chasse a énormément baissé
en donner tout à l'heure des
statistiques qui sont fondés sur les
dernières années mais si on prend par
rapport à l'entre-deux-guerres aux
années 1950 je dirais que c'est presque
la même évolution que pour les accidents
de la route il ya une très forte des
croissants mélodies dans l'almanach
saignant accepte plus cvc dans l'opinion
on n'accepte pas le risque que l'on peut
prendre en allant se promener dans la
forêt puisque la france a une couverture
forestière extrêmement importante alors
c'est vrai que dans certains pays qui
ont une très faible couverture
forestière prenons le canton de genève
ou bien les pays bas le problème est
très différent dans déjà un pays comme
la france qui est un pays qui est très
boisée où il y à un phénomène je dirais
de ruralisation avec des lotissements
périphérique autour des villages vous
avez un contact entre les promeneurs et
les chasseurs qui est très difficile à
régler effectivement il faut développer
tout ce qui concerne la sécurité mais ce
ne sera pas facile parce que on
n'accepte pas l'idée même du du risque
par conséquent
parle ton est différent mais je suis
bien d'accord avec vous mais on est dans
une société qui n'accepte plus moi je
suis d'accord
paris ce que c'est je me promenant fort
qu'est ce qu'on explique aux gens que
s'ils pourront dire que cette mort l'an
dernier et encore et qui encore 500 sur
les sept
districts sommes des gens vikings
comment est ce que vous dites
randonneuse la famille lors de ce monde
est désolé non mais t'as dit
je donne un exemple il est arrivé
dimanche dernier j'étais à la chasse
posté dans les bras un sentier qui monte
ou à chaque cas là chaque entrée de
panneaux y avait marqué attention chasse
en cours et je suis posté au milieu
regarde moi je vois un un vélo qui
arrive au milieu sur le chemin on les
use in dit oui mais moi je suis chez moi
je n'ai pas chez vous monsieur c'est
parce qu'ils voudraient une propriété
privée vous vous promenez là sur un
sentier qui les privait ses marques et
de chaque côté il vient au milieu donc
il ya un risque le risque il le prend
quand même ça vous bien il accorde
seulement la mort dans son jardin
expliqué la fin celui là mais retenez
seulement là je n'ai pas dit que j'ai
pas dit ce que vous avez utilisé dans un
accident qu'est-ce qu'on expliquera on
est désolé c'est un pauvre accidents
vont très bien mais l'acteur de cinéma
qui est mort sur une piste de ski
quelqu'un lui rentre dans notre région
pour lui dise un accident ça ne commence
à
8 mois ça n'arrivait dans son jardin et
chez lui se reçoit une balle et vous
dites c'est comme un accident du travail
et moi je suis sur l'autoroute il m'est
arrivé un accident très grave je roule
sur l'a38 l'attendiez n'est bien je suis
sur la voie une voiture percute en face
de moi qu'est-ce que je n'en attendais
caisse quand je me suis à ce que là on a
eu ce discours willy frenchies parler ce
qui justifia sait déjà c'est un
instrument qui est fait pour tuer donc
on ne peut pas dire ça faisait face à
une voiture années 80 celle au bord
d'une route non respect
non justement que je pense qu'angers
rationnaires les jeux justement je
trouve très dommage et je trouve de la
part des chasseurs que vous représentez
de ne pas avoir justement une position
très pragmatique de dire c'est pas
acceptable que ça soit 6 être que ça
soit dit que ça ce n'est pas acceptable
que qu'elle se promène dans les bois 25
ans perdent la vie et que ça soit une
perceuse le 17 ans qui lui ait tiré
dessus parce que elle aussi sa vie est
foutue des cheveux secs c'est bien mais
je pense qu'il faut partir de ce
principe là et de dire comment on change
les choses que l'on modifie les choses
et quand vous parliez des ruraux et
urbains je pense que tous les
témoignages qu'on peut avoir c'est
plutôt au contraire moi j'étais effaré
par le nombre de témoignages que j'ai pu
avoir mais même deux chasseurs on peut
pas en rester là il faut changer les
choses partent de
là et avant sont plutôt dus à l'essayer
donné la visite et je ne suis pas d
accord
ne vous inquiétez pas la chasse serait
le seul activité je risque zéro devrait
exister jours sans chasse c'est pas si
facile à dire j'ai réussi les autres la
règle enfants c'est que on peut chasser
7 jours sur 7 de septembre à février
alors les dates elles varient en
fonction des départements et je vais
donner la parole à alain des candidats
parce qu'on est en pleine campagne et
présentiel évidemment il s'exprime sur
cette question c'est un marqueur la
question de la chasse
jean luc mélenchon c'était le 20 février
dernier sur effectivement le fait de
sanctuariser un certain nombre de jours
sans chasse est très précis on écoute
pour ce qui concerne les conflits
d'usagé oui il faut il faut que la
chasse ne soit pas possible les
week-ends et pendant les vacances
scolaires parce que c'est là que le
risque serait le plus grand deuxièmement
il faut cesser de vendre des armes qui
sont aussi puissante que celle couvent
et qui sont de l'avis même des
fédérations de chasseurs excessivement
puissante compte tenu des gibiers qui se
chassent en france c'est pas la peine
d'avoir une arme capable d'abattre
rhinocéros en france assez rare n'y a
pas de rhinocéros alors la puissance des
armes on va en parler dans ce débat
votre candidat yannick jadot il dit sur
cette même ligne 10 c'est dans mon
programme depuis longtemps interdire la
chasse les week-ends et les vacances
scolaires je j'entends ça moi je suis
pas chasseur
mon autre dans ce débat j'accompagne des
amis à la chasse de temps en temps voilà
je suis pas un anti chasse et je suis
pas non plus chasseur mais quand
j'entends sable vous voulez quoi obliger
les chasseurs y avait quand même des
millions de français qui pratiquent ce
sport où ce loisir à quoi a posé des rtt
pour pouvoir pratiquer leur jeu moi je
pense cette proposition là elle a eu le
mérite je pense que ben on le voit hélas
j'irai avec l'actualité mais qui a le
mérite de poser cette question là et que
on peut pas indéfiniment j'ai vu barbara
pompiers qui à chaque fois nous dit oui
c'est dramatique mais bon ma derrière on
fait rien donc je pense que et à ce
sujet là mais il faut tout les vagues
sur le fait d'être comme ça de dire
week-end et l'ensemble des vacances
scolaires j'suis pas forcément pour je
pense qu'on a une vraie réflexion à voir
et de regarder juste qui se passe sur
les pays qui nous entourent et je trouve
intéressant sur un certain nombre de
pics en fait l'inversé inverser les
choses c'est à dire qu'on dit on a tant
de jours de chasse possible et donc on
pourrait très bien avoir trois quatre
jours de chasse ça me paraît pas
complètement absurde de couper la
semaine la semaine en deux ensuite ça
peut être une réflexion départementale
parce que oui à des diversités en
fonction des différents départements
avec bien sûr une obligation de ne pas
avoir de chasse le week-end alors ça
peut être le dimanche ça peut être les
après midi du samedi et du dimanche mais
je pense qu'on doit avoir une vraie
réflexion sur comment on partage
justement cet usage de la nature et on
permet à des gens de pouvoir aller se
promener avec leurs enfants
tranquillement sans avoir le risque de
prendre une balle tout simplement les
pays qui interdisent la chasse certains
jours royaume uni le dimanche pour
certaines espèces les pays bas c'est le
dimanche et puis à des dates 1er janvier
pentecôte ascension l'italie c'est un
peu plus complexe mardis et vendredis et
puis limitation à trois jours de chasse
par semaine et le portugal autorisation
seulement le jeudi et le dimanche
andrée corvol a déjà existé en fait pour
le moment ça n'a pas d'existence et
toujours sept jours sur sept pour le
moment mais c'est vrai que s'il y aura
un partage
vraisemblablement de la semaine pour les
chasseurs et pour les nouveaux chasseurs
qu'on y arrivera et le sens inné c'est
le sens de l'histoire moi
mais c'est vrai que ce sera très
difficile à régler pascoe france on a
tendance à uniformiser ce type de
mesures il faudra vraiment que ce soit
pris au niveau des régions et même au
niveau des départements parce qu'il ya
des situations qui sont extrêmement
différentes d'un d'une région à l'autre
et c'est vrai que chasser dans la région
parisienne c'est compliqué en raison de
la densité d'habitants chasser dans ce
qu'on appelle la diagonale du vide où
vous avez une densité qui est inférieur
à 30 40 habitants au kilomètre carré
je dirais c'est quand même plus facile à
organiser
donc effectivement il faut que ce soit
puisse surtout pas au niveau central il
faut descendre au plus bas alors ça
c'est intéressant ça patriat est ce que
on est très voilà on aime bien les
décisions qui tombe de paris enfin c'est
ce que dans le cas particulier pap a au
contraire le plus possible
régionaliser ou départementalisée non je
crois qu'il faut que les règles le soin
nationale après l'organisation de la
chasse elle décentralisée je voudrais
quand même revenir un instant sur ce qui
nous a séparés au début je suis bien
d'accord avec tous les interlocuteurs il
faut aller au risque zéro il faut aller
au risque zéro n'est d'accord il faut
attendre il faut le temple mais le
risque zéro dans les activités humaines
ça n'existe pas elie d'acteur dramatique
qui arrive c'est vrai on peut pas dire
simplement c'est dramatique parce que ça
sa frappe les gens alors moi je suis
effectivement pour le partage des
espèces et des espaces très bien ça vous
réveille toi un jour par semaine mais
alors attendez je vous proposais y avait
dans la loi que je fais j'avais expliqué
aux parlementaires à l'époque qui savez
les gens la société voudra qu'un jour on
chasse plus le dimanche 11 sept aps le
week-end j'avais dit il faut aujourd'hui
donner aux gens qui habitent ou devant
la nature une journée au moins ou savent
qu'il n'ya nulle part en france de la
chasse ce jour là que les gens qui
venaient jamais proposée le mercredi
mardi à l'époque je me souviens que
j'avais eu monsieur singes aux contres -
qui s'était élevé je l'avais réussi à le
faire voter à trois voies dans un débat
houleux à 6 heures du matin dans
l'hémicycle à l'assemblée nationale
masque aliou dia si c'était plat et
s'était plaint et c'était plein j'ai
jamais vu l'hémicycle aussi plaints à 6
heures du matin de ma vie parlementaire
on a peut-être avoir deux ans après ici
je me souviens d'avoir rencontré
ladislas poniatowski qui a repris le
texte de loi j'ai fait voter et qui
enlevait le jour de l'an chance il y
avait des départements qui sent la loi
le faisait avant dans le département où
j'habite on se sait pas nilmar dit neil
vendredi il ya déjà des territoires en
france aux chasses pole dimanche dans
les forêts domaniales dans les forêts
domaniales je prends par exemple chez
moi la forêt de sitôt très belle forêt
domaniale on ne chasse pas le week end
oui mais parce que là on nous chasse
attention elle est beaucoup moins
ouverte que vous n'êtes
frais de tous on peut le faire et
attention parce que quand on regarde sur
la commission départementale
effectivement si on regarde l'ensemble
des départements la plupart c'est un
jour de non chasse qui souvent le
vendredi j'ai regardé effectivement il
ya quelques particularités pas fait si
on regarde la raison pour laquelle on
fait un jour de la chasse c'est pas pour
le partage de la nature c'est pour
l'après de protection du gibier et donc
je pense qu'il faut aussi réfléchir
différemment c'est à dire que maintenant
on doit aussi réfléchir sur ce partage
de la nature et sur le fait que oui à
des gens qui veulent se promener en mai
mais interdire la chasse le dimanche je
dire c'est la fin de la chasse populaire
or la chasse et les populaires aller
dans le littoral aller dans le pas de
calais les dans la somme la chasse
populaire fait c'est la chasse c'est
leur vie ces gens là - jour il ya un
chasseur qui m'a dit tu préfère perdre
ma femme que de perdre ma tonne alors
des comptes parce que tu perds ma tonne
la gamme et ben je pourrais jamais le
remplacer
ma femme y est on y est arrivés à ce
degré là vous entendez ici c est moi je
mettais et moi je m'étais élevé contre
ces coûts set perdu 100 mais je me sens
super bien on a l'exemple quand même
recueilli aucun dans le royaume uni ça
fait depuis 18 51 qui est que la chasse
ne serait pas le dimanche voilà et ça
reste une activité populaire elle
expliqué aux ouvriers qui travaillent en
semaine que
je vous donne la parole enrico rôle
parce que vous avez
mais l'idée que le droit de chasse a été
donné à tous les français au moment de
la révolution française c'est une idée
qui est fausse je suis désolé pour vous
elle a été directrice alizés lorsqu'on à
commémorer le centenaire de 800 process
en 1889 mais en réalité avant 1789 le
droit de chasse existé sauf qu'il était
extrêmement compliqué parce que variable
d'une région à l'autre est valable et
variables également selon le statut
social en gros vous aviez d'une part les
nobles qui disposait de meutes de chiens
et de chevaux qui se chargeait de
l'extermination des prédateurs c'est à
dire de la sécurité des personnes en
organisant la population locale pour les
aider dans les battues et de l'autre
côté vous aviez la chasse que
j'appellerais de paysanne qui ne
pouvaient pas utiliser les armes de tir
c'était donc une chasse silencieuse
destinée je dirais à l'alimentaire on
les appelait les chasses cuisinière et
ce qu'ils avaient droit de chasser
c'étaient les rongeurs et les oiseaux
migrateurs c'est à dire des destructeurs
de récoltes c'était donc la sécurité des
récoltes qui était accordée dans la
mesure où justement leur donner ce droit
de chasse en utilisant des filets des
pièges et c est en 1790 on a n'ont pas
donné la chasse à tout le monde on a
simplifié le dispositif en donnant
précisons que désormais tout homme quel
que soit son statut pourrait pourrait
chasser et cela sur toute terre à
condition d'être propriétaire et la
question est ce qu'on la corde au
propriétaire ou également aux locataires
ç'avait été une grosse question qui a
été débattu pendant la nuit sans
française et cela avec tout tarn et il
faut dire que grâce aux guerres
révolutionnaires il ya beaucoup de
paysans qui sont procuré des armes des
tirs de contrebande et à partir de ce
moment là on pouvait plus faire marche
arrière donc tout problème sous le
consulat et puis sous le premier empire
c'est de savoir comment on allait
contrôler le port des armes et non pas
fluage de larmes c'était la question du
port de la retire on a inventé une taxe
quand il va préparer et oui qui va
préparer l'arrivée du permis de chasse
en 1840 justement jouer leur partition à
faire avancer les choses le résultat
c'est que av avec les mesures qui ont
été prises entre 1790 et 1844 y avait
moins de chasseurs qui en avaient sous
l'ancien régime d'accord donc là on
n'est pas du tout dans l'image qu'on
présente
vous parliez des des armes du permis de
chasse je propose à samia de sheer de de
me rejoindre tout de suite bonsoir samia
bienvenus vous venez de réaliser un
documentaire pour public sénat ça
s'appelle merci de l'exercice elle est
un chasseur sachant chasser jeudi
lentement s'est diffusée samedi sur
notre chaîne et ça parle de notre thème
à la partage partage la nature entre les
chasseurs et non chasseurs mais aussi de
cette portée de la puissance des arbres
oui parce que effectivement il ya un
vrai débat autour de la puissance des
hommes qui qui sont utilisées par les
chasseurs qui sont pas toutes identiques
il ya d'un côté les traditionnels fusil
de chasse qui sont souvent utilisés pour
le petit gibier et qu'ils ont tiré des
cartouches de plomb à quelques centaines
de mètres le plomb ça peut blesser mais
alors pour tuer quelqu'un avec un fusil
et des cartouches de plomb faut vraiment
le chercher tiré à bout portant et puis
pour le gros gibier comme les sangliers
on va utiliser d'autres armes les
carabines qui elles sont beaucoup plus
puissantes avec ça on peut tirer des
balles pas des plombs mais des balles
qui vont être potentiellement mortelle
jusqu'à 3 4 km et la balle qui a tué une
randonneuse le week-end dernier a très
certainement été tirés avec ce type de
carabine tout comme la balle qui avait
tué un automobiliste en octobre dernier
en ille et vilaine on est suivi sur les
lieux de cette année de cet accident
daniel salmon qui est membre d'une
mission sénatoriale qui travaille en ce
moment sur la sécurisation de la chasse
il y était avec la mère de l'oeil et la
commune où c'est arrivé regarder
un chasseur était
sûr
dans le champ au fond là bas qu'on peut
apercevoir derrière les arbres à au
moins entre 500 et 700 mètres de la cad
voix et donc la balle est là elle a
longé la terre en fait parce qu'il était
en surplomb
le chasseur par rapport à la hauteur de
la cad voit la distance c'est
impressionnant quand on voit la densité
de la végétation la balle hélas
forcément rencontré très certainement
rencontrer quand même quelques petits
obstacles mais ça n'a pas arrêté quoi
elle n'a pas pris un tronc donc tant
qu'elles rencontrent pas à tromper
pasqua alors la question c'est combien
de ballons potentiellement traverser
cette même route sans qu'on le sache
sans toucher personne ce qu'on l'a dit
tout à l'heure les accidents de chasse
ils ont fortement diminué depuis une
vingtaine d'années par contre les
incidents de chasse des balles qui vont
atterrir dans le toit d'une maison ou
dans une voiture sans faire de victime
ils sont en forte augmentation pendant
la saison de chasse 2013 2014 la date à
laquelle on a commencé à les recenser il
ya eu 40 incidents de chasse sept ans
plus tard en 2020 2021 en a dénombré 107
ça fait une augmentation quand même de
160% donc forcément les sénateurs qui
travaillent sur le sujet sur le sujet et
se sont demandé est ce que les chasseurs
maîtrise vraiment les armes aussi
puissante qu'ils ont les mains je vous
propose de regarder un extrait de leur
visite dans un stand de tir dans l'ain
le chasseur français
n'est pas un tireur comme peuvent l'être
les autres personnes notamment des pays
nordiques où la culture du tir est
beaucoup plus développé je sens français
lui tire très peu c'est un petit peu
dommage parce que le tir à la chasse est
une gestuelle et que comme toute vêtue
elle va elle doit ce travail elle doit
s'entretenir je pense que une petite
remise à niveau
tous les deux trois cinq ans je ne sais
pas serait grandement grandement
efficace pour en tout cas faire
comprendre aux gens qu'une arme ça se
manipule une certaine façon et pas d'une
autre par contre ne sont pas un amalgame
avec la puissance puisque on se rend
compte là aussi au niveau de
l'accidentologie qu il y ait autant
d'accidents avec des armes que vous
qualifiez de puissantes qui sont les
carabines qu'avec des fusils de chasse
qui sont des dvd armes à canon lisse et
qui on lui porte et qui est très très
très très réduite merci samia pour ses
explications et surtout les extrêmes
notre reportage long format bonne soirée
que l'on peut retrouver donc samedi
18h30 en intégralité sur sur public
sénat et sa pelouse une double
problématique françois patriat est celle
de la puissance des armes puis à celle
de la formation je voudrais commencer
par la formation quand on a le permis de
chasse sont là pour la vie entière il
n'y a pas de ya pas de remise à niveau
il n'y a pas de vérifier l'heure
actuelle il n'y en a pas oui mais moi je
considère qu'aujourd'hui la chasse doit
pas se pratiquer comme ça brutalement 17
de chasseurs moi j'ai appris à chasser
en accompagnant mon père mes frères
alors depuis l'âge de 8 10 ans j'ai
appris à la sécurité j'apprenne à
identifier j'ai appris à ne faisait donc
il faut quand même une formation qui
soit elle est déjà très pointu
aujourd'hui elle et je vais inscrire mon
petit-fils cette année à la chasse oui
même acquisition c'est pas tant le
permis que le suivi le suivent au long
des années c'est ce que disait l'un des
interlocuteurs c'est en fait les
chasseurs ils tirent pas souvent ici ce
tir passait souvent donc est-ce qu'il
faut rendre obligatoire j'en sais rien
une formation tous les cinq ans un
contrôle tous les dix ans
pour le permis de conduire
moi je pense qu'au contraire plus le
chasseur chasse plus l'habitude et plus
qui est contraint de sécurité vous
assure que d'henri mais si on regarde si
on garde son permis de chasse alors
qu'on pratique peu et que finalement on
devient mauvais chasseur nous le danger
devient pas mauvais chasseur parce qu'on
pratique peu les deux sauts sécurité non
mais je veux dire parce que la sécurité
c'est pas une question d'entraînement
tous les jours de chasse et tous les
jours c'est une question de prise de
conscience de respecte de de respect
d'un de savoir manier une arme quand on
ya des gens qui chassent pas et qui
manie désormais kirov sportive qui le
font qu'ils le font beaucoup alors que
maintenant on y est périodiquement une
période de contrôle probatoire au bout
de dix ou vingt ans revenez voir un peu
comment pour peut-être prendre de
nouvelles consignes de sécurité qui ont
évolué savez les angles de tir respecter
maintenant et l'accident donc que vous
ne citez un nom il arrive la personne
qui a tiré la a fait une faute notoire
on ne tire jamais en direction des
routes on ne doit jamais tiré en
direction d'une route quoi tient une
route daries patiemment ses retraits de
permis basson mais là il ya un monde il
paye même y avoir emprisonné en
attendant des acacias vernets pav
retrait de permis
là je parle d'un incident à saint-pardon
partie des désodorisants tic je pense
que bien sûr il ya la question de la
formation ça me paraît indéniable et je
pense que la formation en france allait
pas suffisante
je pense que à la fois le nombre de
jours et le fait de revenir je pense
qu'on peut pas attendre dix ans il y
aura un moment donné à voir une arme
c'est pas n'importe quoi et donc il faut
qu'ils aient des temps de formation
régulier pour parce qu'on oublie ou
parce que aussi on prend des habitudes
aussi et donc je pense que c'est
nécessaire qu'on est con et ce retour
mais il ya aussi la question des
sanctions qui peuvent être amenées moi
je sais que en tant que maire j'ai eu
plusieurs fois des problématiques de
chasseurs justement qui tirait alors
qu'il ne devait pas dans des 10 dans
certaines directions dire qui était
louis dangereux avec avec leurs fusils
de faire remonter à la fédération
réellement une sanction qui est un
retrait de permis je peux dire que c'est
très long et pas facile donc je pense
que là aussi
la fédération
en tout cas je peux dire que quand il ya
un constat comme ça c est donc là il ya
peut-être aussi à améliorer les choses
parce que je pense qu'on peut pas
accepter quelqu'un qui ne respecte pas
les règles et qui est dangereux du coup
pour les autres il faut très vite
justement pouvoir le pouvoir les cartes
et donc ça ça fait ça fait partie des
éléments et puis effectivement sur le
troisième aspect c'est la question de la
puissance des armes qui pose quand même
question c'est vrai que le fait de se
dire qu'on peut tuer quelqu'un à deux
voire trois kilomètres oui ça pose des
questions parce que là on voit bien ce
qui a été montré c'est qu'on est à plus
de plus de 800 mètres d'une voie et que
oui à ce risque et je pense que ça pose
aussi du coup la question on parlait des
jours sans chasse je pense qu'il ya
aussi des zones sans chasse sur lequel
il faut peut-être réfléchir territoire
par territoire moi je le pense notamment
sur les chemins de grande randonnée sur
des zones touristiques je ne comprends
pas l'exemple que je donnais sur sur
belledonne en isère c'est un chemin de
randonnée quand on voit le nombre de
personnes qui ceux qui se promènent
l'époque quand c'est arrivé c'est y
avait du brouillard mais en plus c'est
dit c'est pas possible même avec des
panneaux qu'on puisse chasser ici quoi
c'est pas possible andrée corvol ça
c'est effectivement une piste de nos
réflexions certainement une piste de
réflexion mais c'est ce sont vraiment
des réflexions qui sont tout à fait
nouvelle il ya trente ans
la société n'aurait pas du tout réfléchi
de cette façon
alors qu'aujourd'hui on pense à la fois
à la préservation des espèces et en même
temps à la préservation des promeneurs
alors que jusqu'à la première guerre
mondiale on réfléchit c'est uniquement à
l'égalité entre les chasseurs et à
l'accessibilité aux territoires de
chasse les débats ce sont donc
complètement déplacé et donc là nous
avons de nouvelles questions il va
falloir apporter de nouvelles réponses
pour pouvoir effectivement sécurisé et
surtout pacifier l'espace entre les
chasseurs et les non chasseurs parce
qu'on ne peut pas supprimer la chasse
comme ça parce que dans ce cas là on
fait comment pour la régulation du
gibier et en particulier des espèces pro
différentes c'est à dire l'ensemble
déambuler les sangliers et les cervidés
on a un vrai problème de dégradation
agricole et de dégradation forestière
mathieu vous ce qui vous a frappé
accident la route quand on quand on a à
préparer des bananiers l'épaule et les
politiques qui sont quand même ils font
preuve de beaucoup de mansuétude vis à
vis des sièges par aucun lien en rien ce
même fou je trouve au nom de la défense
des traditions au nom de la défense de
la ruralité au nom aussi du poids
électoral que peuvent représenter ces
amoureux de la gâchette la classe
politique fait preuve d'une grande
compréhension voire d'une forme de
complaisance à l'égard de cette pratique
regardez au lendemain du drame qui a vu
mourir cette jeune randonneuse le week
end dernier
mais y'en a qu'on fait preuve d'une
grande retenue parmi les candidats on
n'a pas beaucoup entendu les répètes
crès ni eric zemmour dit jean lassalle
nicolas dupont aignan qui avaient tous
été comme par hasard éviter quelques
jours auparavant à clamer leur amour de
la chasse devant le mouvement de la
ruralité qu'elle héritier de l'ancien
parti lobby de chasse pêche nature et
tradition c'est étonnant parce qu'en
fait c'est souvent le premier à réagir
aux premiers faits divers où on prenait
un rodéo urbain qui fait courir des
risques aussi à des gens qui fait du
bruit équipe avec lequel on peut mourir
ou faire mourir là tout le monde tout le
monde sort les dents ça sera scandale
prix d'achat ce qui est une pratique
réguler et encadrer autorisé comme le
rôdeur urbains là c'est pas possible et
je disais devant ce grand oral devant
les chasseurs on a tout entendu pour
valérie pécresse il fallait arrêter de
faire la chasse aux chasseurs enfin eric
zemmour lui il s'enflamme régulièrement
des gens des vrais écologistes c'est
vous les vrais amateurs de la nature
c'est vous ce qui est un peu du grand
n'importe quoi faut bien le dire parce
que rappelle à toutes fins utiles que
personne personne ne propose de
supprimer la chasse en france n'ont pas
même les écologistes qui propose de
réserver un jour où les vacances
scolaires pour
partie
des candidats des candidats à la
présidentielle personne ne propose ça
dans cette campagne présidentielle
absolument personne quant à la
régulation qu'il soit un argument
invoqué le patron des chasseurs français
lui même a dit mais la régulation j'en
ai rien à [__] texto s'était il a
prononcé on n'est pas là pour réguler là
pour se faire plaisir c'est quand même
assez l'un des motifs pour donner c'est
une affaire de passion et non pas de
régulation et quand vous mettez en avant
la régulation en général les chasseurs
passionnés vous tombe dessus
quand même sur la régulation faudrait
remettre aussi les choses en place vous
parliez des cervidés effectivement moins
chanceux zone de montagne sur la forêt
ça a des impacts assez fort sur le
je me souviens aussi dans les années 90
que ce sont les chasseurs qui ont
réintroduit des cervidés pour voilà pour
avoir des cervidés pouvoir tuer et qui
était pas du tout des espèces liés au
territoire donc on voit bien que bah là
pour le coup là non seulement à
l'implantation de cervidés c'est oui
bien développés mais que la régulation
n'a pas su faire quoi et que maintenant
on est totalement dépassée qu'on a la
même chose sur les sangliers avec un
coût économique très fort et du coup un
confort
les agriculteurs parce qu'avec donc sur
la question de la régulation je pense
qu'on est très loin de quelque chose
d'efficace et qu'on a plutôt une gestion
je dirais de la faune sauvage
plutôt pour pour la préserver pour
pouvoir retourner à la chasse plutôt
créatures une réelle régulation donc ça
aussi c'est vraiment des choses c'est
intéressant on revient sur le peut-être
le l'aubisque oui c'est un lobby très
brillant et très très bien implantés et
très très bien il ya beaucoup de relais
parmi les élus je disais ça nourrit très
bruyant moi je me souvient françois
patriat il faisait allusion quand la loi
a été votée député socialiste de la
somme qui avait été pris actionner non
défendez les choisir mais un député
c'est ce qu'a dû être évacués par la
police mais c'est la plus grande
présence sur l'éducation nationale
exactement
personnes maison que c'est un lobby kaki
et même représenter il ya beaucoup
d'appuis y compris au sein des exécutifs
à emmanuel macron a fêté ses 40 ans
devant un tableau de chasse au château
de chambord ont lassé rappelé la mise et
non non non non je voudrais rétablir la
vérité sur il y était tout le monde a
trop lu le livre noël à chambord katanec
et à
signer notre chasse à chambord je vais
vous dire exactement la
vérité
la vérité deux minutes le présent la
république souhaite avant à l'endroit
ses petits-enfants et moi c'est moi je
lui conseille à l'époque d'aller louer
un gîte autour de chambord pour lui
qu'ils empruntent où il va il paye son
gîte pipe et le hebei tout est dit comme
j'arrive le vendredi soir et qu'il ya
une battues de régulation le vendredi
j'irai salué les chasseurs au tableau
alors on a dit qu'il y avait des oiseaux
n'ya pas d'oiseau à chambord j'ai juste
dit qu'il avait
visé par deux le prix de son
gouvernement regardez sur les chasses
traditionnelles a essayé de de ménage et
d'un t-shirt loose et fait la
chasse à la glu mais enfin bref voilà
bref ce lobby est pris aux tables et
alors que l'opinion change quand même 61
% des français sont pour réserver des
jours le week end ou des vacances et
puis je pense qu'il ya quelque chose qui
change aussi c'est que la chasse fait
plus forcément recettes en politique il
ya plus de candidats chasseur alors vous
me dire ils ont même plus besoin d en
revanche beaucoup diminué je vais dire
une candidate du parti animalistes et
qui a fait quand même 2 16% à peu près
le score qu'elle fait
eric news dernière fois et qui pour
l'instant du mal à
ce que c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut
qu'on retienne ces cas une vraie attente
de la population et je le redis encore
une fois c'est pas les ruraux contre les
urbains voilà c'est c'est globalement et
même chez les chasseurs c'est pour ça
que moi je le dis souvent c'est plutôt
un conseil envers les chasseurs prenez
vraiment le sujet à bras le corps gers
et le moment c'est maintenant il faut le
faire il ya cette possibilité a et on
est on sait on voit bien sur les trois
axes sur lequel on peut travailler je
pense qu'on pourra plus reculées
françois patriat mot de conclusion est
ce que effectivement moi j'ai le
sentiment à vous entendre là vous n'avez
pas entendre nos arguments que vous vous
êtes plus prêt à bouger que la
fédération elle-même quoi est ce que est
ce que ils sont sourds aux arguments de
certains membres de la fédération santé
sont bloqués sur une position qui est la
suivante si on cède sur quelque chose ce
sera le doigt dans l'engrenage et après
on aura tous si on cède sur la chasse
agrée tôt je crois qu'il faut pâture de
position totalement bloqué il faut
entendre que dit la société il faut
entendre les drames qui se passe il faut
comprendre que le monde a changé faut
comprendre aujourd'hui on peut re vous
avez parlé des réintroductions mais donc
effectivement il faut sur la sécurité
être plus exigeant encore sur le
maniement des armes plus exigent encore
aujourd'hui le faire demain c'est à
nouveau il faut faire de la pédagogie de
l'éducation et 2 et de la sanction et de
la sanction côté des conduites qui sont
inappropriées ou dangereuses merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat andré corman j'appelle le
titre de votre histoire de la chasse
l'homme et la bête on y était à aux
éditions perrin merci à toutes et à tous
de votre fidélité